Hey guys!
I'd like to introduce my girlfriend, Jessica.
Hi guys!
Hi.
Oh, Jessica we've heard a lot about you.
Takes a lot to hang with this wild man.
C'mon guys.
We were gonna play "Never Have I Ever."
Oh, what's that?
You've never played?
Uh, no.
Oh, it's super fun.  So everybody puts their hands up.
And somebody says something they've never done
and if you've done it you put a finger down.
Okay I'm going to go first.  Never have I ever
been skydiving.
Woa, both of you?
I never knew that about you.
Yeah, it's super awesome.
Oh, she's a badass chick.
Yeah.  Uh, okay so.
Never have I ever had sex on the beach.
Oh Brad, we've got a wild cat over here.
It was in Ibiza for Spring Break.
You don't have to explain yourself.
We've all been young once, right?
Okay I have never been arrested.
Uh, never have I ever had a PB & J.
Not even once?
No.
Never have I ever peed on someone.
Okay, never have I ever set a public library on fire.
Never have I ever put slugs near but not on
my vagina.
Never have I ever eaten 4 pounds of dog food.
Never have I ever read someone's lines
and discovered that their lives were crossed with mine
inextricably and killed them.
Never have I ever worked a Summer Program
for At Rest Teens and convinced them all
to continue their education.
Never.
Have I
Ever
President
Hand model
Pay for tickles
Red nephew
Woa.
You're like the coolest chick I know.
Yeah, I don't know how to process all of this information.
Oh, well you don't have to.
Why?
Uh, never have I ever robbed a bunch of idiots.
Give me your money.
I like just overdrew my account.
Babe--
Give me the money.
Okay, all right.  I just took you out to Yogurtland, I--
Give me.
I can have my dad PayPal you.
That's fine.
My grandfather took this from the war.
Fine I'll take it.
Ok.
Call me.
Wait, me?
Call me!
Oh...Okay.
You better call her.
Is she gone?
Hey guys!  So that sketch was weird.
But you know, can't be an Anna video without a prop gun in there.
I just wanted to say a few things
Ghost and Stars was on the red carpet for the Streamy Awards.
VH1 called me one of the best dressed.
And actually you can't see but there's studs on this jacket.
So I have a bunch of new stuff coming out in Fall on Ghost and Stars.
So you should check it out because VH1 really likes it.
Also I have a bunch of new Stand Up shows coming out
but the one I hope you really come to is on October 6th
at the Ontario improv.
So this is actually my show.  It's "Anna Akana presents Show and Tell."
It's all of my favorite Asian female comedians and of course Brad for diversity.
But it's actually like a test run and if it goes well
I may go on tour across the United States and possibly other countries.
So yeah if you've always wanted to see me do some Stand Up, come on down and check it out.
And finally I want to say thanks so much to Squarespace
for making this episode happen!
And someone asked me to do it in Marcel The Shell
so here she goes!
I want to say thank you to SquareSpace for sponsoring today's episode.
SquareSpace makes it really easy to make a website
because there are like simple drag and drops
and easy to use tools and
really great landing pages.
You can get a free trial with no credit card down
or it's just $8.00 a month
and if you sign up it comes with a free domain.
You can go to Squarespace.com/Anna
for 10% off
That's Squarespace.com/Anna
I'm Marcel the Shell.  Stay awesome Gotham.
Oh there's a cat here.  I'll go sit next to the cat and pet it.
I hope it doesn't eat me.
Never have I ever slept inside a refrigerator.
Never have I ever fallen through a skylight when I was spying on my neighbor.
Never have I ever won funniest home videos by getting my balls punched.